et puis vous vous avez pas vous avez pas
le collègue qu'on m'a dit hier les gars
là oui j'ai des ennuis d'abord je vais
faire à la maison
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il a ce beau monsieur
et voilà tu vois mon petit grand
d'accord
on vient vous chercher de loin comme ça
quelquefois
de l'autre côté d'Aubusson
dans la Creuse
alors là
avec la démolie encore
[Musique]
oui
comment
était infirmier militaire moi j'ai fait
4 mois de pavillon chirurgie
on est en soldat
et c'est là que vous avez appris
l'anatomie
ça vous embête vraiment au contraire ça
me saoule
mais vous soignez aussi bien les les
gens que les bêtes
si c'est des modules conséquences
toutes les articulations des mollye les
muscles les entorses tout ce que vous
et puis vous vous avez pas le courant
là moi j'ai des ennuis
[Musique]
ça se termine toujours comme ça monsieur
vidéo
les médecins
on vient vous déranger quelques fois la
nuit
comment voulez-vous que je travaille à
musculaire
au premier coup parce que ça fait mal ça
m'étonne pas
quel âge vous avez monsieur bio 75 ans
on a on a une philosophie de la vie
qu'est-ce que oui on s'en fout on attend
comment ça va la poche
[Applaudissements]
je soussigné vidéo Jean-Louis
faculté de médecine de Clermont-Ferrand
vous avez légué votre corps à la
médecine pourquoi
s'ils font des expériences
vous avez envie d'être utile encore
après votre mort si on peut
tout ce qu'on fait là
une fois qu'on est mort
[Musique]
s après vous quand vous serez plus là
le bon Dieu
[Musique]
président de la République
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]